OK.
Let's talk a little bit about the drug test
thing, because I think that there is actually
a story here.
Donald Trump continues to request that he
and Joe Biden be drug tested either before
or after the upcoming presidential debate.
The debate is tomorrow.
I hope you'll watch it with me live on YouTube,
Twitter, Facebook.
And there is a piece of this story that is
distraction.
And there's a piece of this story that is
projection.
So let's talk about each.
Donald Trump for a while has been saying Joe
Biden's performance against Bernie Sanders
during that debate, it was too good.
Biden must have been on something recently
saying that Joe Biden got a shot of something.
Remember this clip from last week?
The gloves off.
This guy doesn't have a clue.
He doesn't know where the hell he is.
And they'll give him a shot at something.
I don't know.
He's going to get something.
He'll be, you know, because I watched him
so badly.
He performed so badly in the debates and then
with Bernie.
He was average, not great, but he got through.
And I said, what the hell is he taking?
And we'd like to ask him.
And I said that we want to drug test.
We want to test the bouquet.
There's the idea again.
And yesterday, Donald Trump again brings this
up by tweeting, quote, I will be strongly
demanding a drug test of sleepy Joe Biden
prior to or after the debate on Tuesday night.
Naturally, I will agree to take when also
his debate performances have been record setting,
uneven, to put it mildly.
Only drugs could have caused this discrepancy.
I continue to get the sense that there is
projection here.
Trump talking so much about performing better
in public speaking events because of drugs,
because of being on something.
And meanwhile, the speculation has been raging
for years that it's Trump who is on something.
And in reality, it is as specific as Trump
says in the tweets, but about himself.
It's Trump's public speaking performances
that are so uneven that it raises questions.
We've casually called it upper Trump versus
Downer, Trump or Adderall, Trump versus Benzo
Trump.
But the point is what Trump points out in
Biden, these uneven performances.
That's exactly what has raised the alarm about
Donald Trump.
Trump sometimes a very sweaty with dilated
pupils, even in front of bright lights, talking
quickly.
Verbal glitches, the shoulder and the the
elbow spasms that we've noticed other times.
It's a different person to different guy.
It's a slowed down.
Trump seems sad and low energy almost since
Ambulante like his sleep talking sleepwalking.
So that's the projection piece that Trump
seems.
To be pointing out in Biden what we observe
in Trump, the distraction pieces that even
if Trump is on drugs, Trump must know that
there is not going to be an actual drug test
before the debate or after the debate.
So he can tweet about it and talk about it
with no actual risk that he will be drug tested.
And that is what is meant as distraction.
It's a distraction from, you know, pick your
poison corona virus.
The tax story, his attempts to rig the election
in his favor.
Whatever.
And by the way, in the meantime, we are about
24 hours, 30 hours as of right now from the
first debate.
Does anybody in my audience think either candidate
will back out?
Because from day one, you've had Trump and
friends saying Joe Biden's going to find a
way out so that he doesn't have to do it.
And in the meantime, you've had some on the
left saying Trump's going to be the one who
finds a way out.
Maybe it'll be bone spurs or, you know, whatever
at this late stage, just a day before the
first debate.
If you think either candidate will back out
for this reason or that reason or for whatever
reason that the debate isn't going to happen.
I would love to hear from you.
Now, just one last thought on this.
Is it possible that Donald Trump is raising
the drug test issue so that when the Commission
on Presidential Debates doesn't require drug
tests, which they obviously will not Trump
can say, I'm not doing it if we're not drug
testing, I'm not doing it because I think
Joe Biden is on something.
A few people emailed me that idea over the
weekend.
I'm running it by you to see what you think.
Right now, I believe the debate happens.
But what on earth do I know?
But I do think at least the first debate happens.
Maybe if it goes horribly wrong for one or
the other candidate, maybe they'll try to
figure out a way not to have the second and
third debates.
But I believe tomorrow's debate happens if
you disagree with me.
Let me know.
We have a voicemail number, which you can
call anytime.